[Applause]
george
[Applause]
george i i don't i don't uh i i don't
know if you're aware of this but uh the
woman sitting next to you
there's a woman sitting next to you
all right that right there is julia
roberts totally crashing pal george
clooney's interview on jimmy kimmel live
while promoting the new movie he
directed the tender bar which stars ben
affleck george hopped on a zoom call
with jimmy and one of the film's stars
10 year old daniel raniri just as jimmy
asks daniel a very important batman
question julia unexpectedly slides in
frame next to george daniel who's your
favorite batman ben affleck or george
clooney oh my goodness
holy moly
george i i don't know if you're aware of
this but the woman sitting next to you
there's a woman sitting next to you
all right
wow
[Laughter]
maybe i hallucinated that i don't know
wow it sure looked like julia roberts
though it's always fun the actress's
surprise appearance caught everyone off
guard making daniel forget to answer the
batman question so daniel you um you oh
you didn't tell us who's your favorite
batman affleck or clooney christian bale
christian
[Applause]
but back to julia it's pretty crazy the
oscar winner is currently filming the
movie ticket to paradise in australia
with you guessed it her longtime
collaborator george here they are on set
you can see george julia and their
co-stars caitlyn dever and billy lord i
feel so grateful to to be doing what i'm
doing and to
and to
be enjoying it and to be working back in
september et chatted with caitlyn as she
gushed over working with the hollywood
legends we have you playing george
clooney and julia roberts daughter are
you just constantly feeling pinch me
moments or does it feel like you know
what at the end of the day this is just
my job i can't even comprehend the idea
of george clooney and julia roberts
being my parents
but they are going to be my parents soon
and i don't know how i i need to just be
normal i just need to figure out how to
be
how to be calm for that introduction um
because they're the two of them like one
of them is is a lot but then two of them
at once is like
oh
it's just a lot um so
i just really don't know how to i really
feel like
super grateful and i'm so excited
um i'm gonna go to australia for the
first time in my life to make that movie
and it's gonna be very fun